hello
and good morning good afternoon good
evening to everyone i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message for
today
may 20th 2021 i've had a very
productive day already i did an hour on
fox news this morning i was on
outnumbered with the ladies of fox news
if you don't think that there are
genders that exist in the universe you
should just watch outnumbered because
they have four
female co-hosts and then they have one
male co-host
i was the male and obviously they were
female so
i don't know should that show be allowed
on tv who the hell knows now it's a
great show harris faulkner is a
fantastic host
and all the ladies are wonderful we got
a lot going on today we are doing
a q a we had dozens and dozens if not
over 100 questions
submitted at rubinreport.locals.com but
before
we get to all the questions and we tried
to mix them up as much as possible today
i want to show you a video of this crazy
alcoholic psychotic woman uh named nancy
pelosi take a look
we all hopeful and i joined the
president being hopeful
that we can reach a place where
it is safe for people to be what is this
the honor system
the honor system as to whether somebody
has been vaccinated
do you want them breathing in your face
on the strength of their honor
so let's just see let's just see i mean
again we have
this is about science and governance
and science and governance we have a
responsibility
to make sure of that the house of the
representatives
chamber is not a petri dish
for the because of the selfishness of
some not to be vaccinated
or to insist or to wear them at it
because it can someone just find me a
remotely sane democrat
like not fully sane i think that the
ship has sailed on that and unless you
have a time machine probably go back now
to the 1800s maybe we could find some
yes i know jfk okay
um these people have completely lost
their minds
and i do wonder when nancy pelosi got
her most recent
recent injections or face lift or
whatever she got was she wearing the
mask
the whole time and were you allowed to
do that under her very own regulations
we do know that she got a haircut when
she had closed down
you know other barber shops and all that
stuff but she said something there that
i thought was really interesting
she said what are we going to do we're
going to trust in the honors system
that's kind of what a free civil society
does nancy now i know that's not really
the society that you're
trying to usher in and the authoritarian
lunatics who follow you are trying to
usher in right
you want the government to tell everyone
what
to do at all times including what they
should have injected in their arm and
what they should
wear on the face and what type of jobs
they should have and how much they
should be paid for those jobs etc etc i
get you want
absolute complete control but that is
the worst sort of fear-mongering because
she wants you to be afraid
of your neighbor and in many ways this
is the
anti-vaxx position she has been
vaccinated
everyone she is in contact with is
thomas massey who's a congressman from
kentucky i mentioned this yesterday he
tweeted out that
in congress right now almost no one is
wearing masks privately meaning the
security
meaning the congress people the staff
etc etc it's
only when these clowns like nancy pelosi
go out on television or go into congress
when they're being filmed on c-span et
cetera et cetera
that do they put that is when they put
the masks on so
it's all theater it's all nonsense and
she's anti-vaxxed
because you know what if the vax works
and i'm to believe that it works right
that's what we're being told it works
i'm not anti-vaxx if the vax works well
then
if a few people are out there that
aren't vaxxed
and they cough in your face nancy well
you shouldn't get sick if the vax works
and by the way
they also frame it sort of that it's
either going to be vaccinated people and
everyone else is going to be diseased
and it's just like no actually the
people who don't get facts will
eventually hit herd immunity we know
people aren't just dropping dead left
and right and in many cases we've all
just moved on whatever the reality of
covid was
something has broken in the last week or
so everyone can kind of feel it now
we're all just moving on
but they can't let go of the control
that they attained in all of this and
that is the problem now for the record i
would not want nancy pelosi breathing in
my face because i'm sure
the woman is swigging grain alcohol in
the morning and you know what that's
like that breath
that kind of burns your eyes and and
nobody should have to deal with that and
i i wouldn't want to listen to
her talk anyway but these are ridiculous
people she talks this is she says this
is about science and governance
well a she doesn't believe in science
that's become very clear because she had
people wearing masks
even after they were told not to and the
only thing
that she believes in is governance
meaning that that is the end all and be
all for her the power that she can wield
over you common people and we should not
pay much attention
unfortunately she never says words like
liberty freedom individual rights
constitution
you know that kind of stuff that that
old school stuff
anyway i don't like you nancy pelosi
okay let's move on we got a whole bunch
from the q a so here we go keith says
if not caitlyn jenner what republican
slash conservative in california
should run a gun against ga
against governor gruesome um well look
i said it on the show yesterday it is my
belief at this point
that the caitlyn jenner thing is is just
a hoax it's not real they put out a good
campaign ad she did one
interview with um sean hannity but in
essence we've reached out all through
all the private channels that you
possibly can i've reached out publicly
and everything else
and it doesn't matter it's not i'm not
making this about me whether she has to
do this show like that would prove
if she was legit but she's not doing
other media and it's not
that that they're just not doing it the
fact that they haven't responded either
shows you have completely incompetent
people beneath you
or this is just some theater thing to
get your name out there so you can have
a reality show and my gut feeling is
that there probably is
a crew of reality show people around her
in the midst of this thing so it is my
belief that the whole thing is a hoax it
is a sham
and i basically i'm not going to be
talking about caitlyn jenner anymore i
just don't think it's real
unfortunately we don't have a great crop
uh you know there's a couple
other people a few of you have mentioned
a few names your question is though
who should run like who should run well
you know i suppose if we could reanimate
the corpse of ronald reagan that would
be nice
but i don't know if there's time for
that before the uh before the recall
happened so that one would be tough
i guess the question is is there a sane
republican who would want to do this run
in a one-party state go against the
machine go against the hate
you know in essence is there a sort of
trump of
of california and i know there's decent
guys by the way i like that i like major
williams
kevin faulkner who i think is the he was
the mayor of san diego
is or was he was the mayor of san diego
there are a couple of decent guys out
there
the question is can they ever get enough
juice uh to make a move
maybe we'll do a friday show i'll get a
couple of the panel i'll get a couple of
the candidates on that that would be
just fine i'm happy to
i'm happy to support anyone that's sane
and yes anyone literally anyone would be
better than newsom
the homeless guy who lives on the corner
over here who's talking to himself all
day and peeing in the bucket
i would vote for him over gavin newsom
um
so i don't know like who is that person
is there a
i don't know it would have to be someone
with celebrity power so i don't know is
it a jon
voight i mean you know john's obviously
older at this point
but is there like a celebrity
say conservative leaning sane minded
person in california who would be
willing to do it and it just doesn't
look like that person exists
and i think we should all act
accordingly and make decisions for
ourselves with that in mind and i speak
for myself when i say that
owen says how about a brief word on how
you feel about trump's statement
quote they aren't coming for me they are
coming for you
i just got in the way yeah i mean i
agree with that and i think i've said
many times over the last couple months
you know trump to me was the guy
guarding the gate the barbarians were at
the gate
and as douglas murray said all the
elites were basically instead of going
hey maybe we need to help the guy at the
gate maybe we need to fortify the gate
we got problems the barbarians are about
to bust into the castle
all the elites were going oh what gender
pronouns should we call the people on
the other side of the gate are those
she's or he's or they's or hers or
or ziers or whatever the hell they are
and trump in essence was the guy that
said hey i'm here
for the common man i know it's an odd
thing because i'm a billionaire and i'm
orange and i got this funny hair
but i'm sort of standing here and
staking my ground which is i think one
of the most important things if not the
most important thing you can do as a
human being
say this is what i believe i am here
and trump was willing to play a
horrifically dirty game that involves
doing
bad things and lying and cheating and
all the that they do by the way and
he was willing to do it back to them
and that's what republicans usually
aren't willing to do
i would also say that you know tucker to
some degree one of the things
that i've often said about tucker is
that the reason that media matters and
mainstream media and the washington post
and all of these fraudulent
organizations the reason they're always
coming for tucker
is not because they just want to take
out tucker carlson it's not for a
singular
hatred of tucker carlson but it's more
because it's like oh
wait if they can take him out well they
took out the president not only did they
take out the president they wiped him
off social media
they wiped him off social media okay not
only did they take out the president but
now they took out tucker you know
the highest rated show in the history of
cable news
and that's why it's important that these
people in many ways are acting as
proxies for you i i suppose i
am at some level and that's why the new
york times just in the last two weeks
said that this was a white supremacist
show or something to that effect
and and i at this point i can just kind
of laugh it off um
but it it belies a much bigger problem
which is that we need more and more
people to stand up because
eventually just people won't you know
what i mean like so many people don't
already but then the few that might
are just going to be like what's the
point what's the point if people
don't back me uh patrick says dave do
you think when the next pandemic
inevitably turns up
the american people will be as compliant
and unquestioning
as this time well first i would say you
know for the first few weeks
say three weeks four weeks even of this
pandemic we had never faced anything
like this
let's put aside whether whether you
think it came from a lab or from a bat
or how mismanaged it might have been or
what states couldn't put all that aside
for a second we had never faced anything
like this in in our modern times right
pretty much everyone watching this had
never faced anything like this
and and if you did i'd like to know your
story
um so those few weeks we all did what we
were supposed to do i mean
i think one of the biggest lies out
there is that somehow if only we had
done
all the stuff at the beginning if trump
had only said scared people more
and we should have done all of this
stuff that none of this would have ever
happened and it's like no
everyone everywhere kept masks on
war gloves all of the stuff for a couple
weeks and then of course then there was
the cascade
of endless lockdowns and all the
horrible stuff in answering your
question
as to whether people will be as
compliant and unquestioning
i think that our elite class and what i
would
i would say the the fouchies at the
science and government level
to the governors is i'm looking at you
newsom and cuomo and some of the other
ones
um they've they've blown their
credibility so what i think is going to
happen there is going to be
a furthering of the the disconnection
of america which i think maybe is a good
thing ultimately that people will just
go
to places that are in line with the way
they believe you guys all know my
thoughts on that
and what i think will happen is when the
next thing comes whether it's covid for
or whether it's they want climate
lockdowns or they're going to tell you
that the zombies
you know show up at night i think what
will happen is places like florida
and texas and some of the other red
places
let's say tennessee a couple others
they're going to stay open they're going
to fight it and they're going to
let people make choices for themselves
because they learn their lesson
and the blue people will just they will
just fold like wet paper bags i mean
i think that's really what will happen i
think so in many ways it'll be much
healthier because there was a test
run if you look at it this way that in
the last year and a half we were all
tested we were tested at an individual
level right all of us were tested what
are we made of what are we listening
what are we listening to what are we
willing to believe do we accept
facts like where do we balance fear and
liberty all of the stuff right
and then we were tested at a societal
level like how much can they push us and
how easily do we just
crumble and it's fairly obvious that a
lot of people do crumble and a lot of
people i mean i went i don't leave my
house that often here in los angeles but
i had an appointment
on the other side of the hill the uh
yesterday and the amount of people
wandering around
outside 75 degrees sunny day
la in masks it's it's just bananas so
uh i think i think we will all let's put
it this way i think
you watching this right now you will do
a better job
this guy will do a better job and the
people around us will do a better job
uh jacob says how are you feeling about
being jewish in america the only people
i hear speaking up for the jews or
fellow jews the left is silent so first
of all i want to say that i've seen a
lot of people
stand up for the jews including nikki
haley and megan mccain and plenty of
others and plenty of non-public
people but to the heart of your question
i mean this is
this is kind of the 5 000 year old story
of the jews you know i mean if you look
at every
jewish holiday it's like you know what
they tried to kill us they killed a
bunch of us
some of us survived now let's eat like
that that's kind of
the story right that's that's the story
that's it's a it's a brutal
history somehow jews survive it right i
mean
you know in essence what's the what's
the story of hanukkah that's the one
that is sort of the most
uh ubiquitous in american society i mean
it's it's the story
of the maccabees the jews that were
living in the judean hills
right judean might have something to do
with the word jewish that's where the
west bank is now it used to be called
judea and samaria that's what it always
was called basically until 1976.
uh sorry 1967. um it's the story of them
defending their land
against the greeks now the funny part of
this is rashida talib who's
you know the worst sort of modern
anti-semite and terrorist sympathizer
and all that stuff
um she during hanukkah for the last
couple years she'll always send out a
happy hanukkah tweet and it's like well
lady
you do know that the happy hanukkah
thing that you're wishing to the jewish
people is a defense of them living
in their land that was thousands and
thousands and thousands of years ago a
place that you don't want any of them to
live now because you call it the west
bank
and you don't want any of them to live
there or that jesus guy who lived in
bethlehem and bethlehem's in the west
bank and that jesus guy happened to be a
jew
i mean everything's so crazy but i would
say um
it's a little scary i suppose it's a
little scary i suppose but i would
rather
stand up for what i believe in and fight
for
my life and the life of my family and
friends and the right ideals that i
always preach here
and be hated than to bow and be loved
and i think a lot of people
right now are trying to just bow and be
loved and
i not only do i not want to do that and
i will never do that
i don't think it's a way it's not a way
to live it's not a way to live and if
you think
i think a lot of jews do feel this at
some level you they're just like ah
the left's not so bad these people sure
there's you know
mobs of palestinian activists attacking
jews on the streets of la and in london
or whatever but
if i'm kind of quiet if i'm kind of good
if i kind of
deny my history or something like that
like i'll skate by
it's like you know hitler didn't didn't
go oh were you a little more jewy than
this jew
and then we'll figure it out that way
right like that's just not how it works
so i i think you must you know
you must fight for your right to live
and and exist and i think most i
actually think i mean this is the
this is the thing that social media has
done to so many people
people think that because things get
ratioed on twitter or
the numbers are this or that or a
zillion people hate you
it's like one of the things that i've
noticed on twitter lately is all the
hate that i get is always bumped to the
top and the people that support me i
have to scroll and scroll and scroll i
don't really look at my mentions anymore
because of this because if i tweet
something out a gajillion people who
hate me
and say awful things those always get
pushed to the top and then i have to
click
view more and it's usually view more for
like hateful material or something and i
click it and it's like
i'm with you dave you know enjoy this oh
you want to see this meme
so we're being manipulated in crazy ways
i actually think most people
um stand with democracy stand with
freedom
and as neil ferguson who i had on the
show who's an incredible
historian from stanford if you haven't
seen that interview the guy is just an
absolute powerhouse we did it a couple
a couple years ago you know can we link
to that actually maybe my interview with
neil
we'll link to it in the description here
um we did it in july
man that was july of 2019. so a long
time ago he's actually also ion hersey
ali's husband which a lot of people
don't know
um but he talked about how basically
israel is sort of like the thing that
the left hates the most because they
know if they can take that out
take out the history of that and the
freedom and the idea that people can
return to their ancient homeland well
then you can basically destroy the rest
of the west
so there is a battle for the west there
is a battle for the west happening right
now
neil says do you think employers in blue
areas will essentially create a caste
system
with restrictions lifted for vaccinated
employees only so i actually got some
interesting information that michael
told me right before this
so the in california here the
occupational
and health standards board has basically
just put out a guideline
that you can now return to work if
you're vaccinated
and with social distancing but
because they're not going to test anyone
for vaccinations at this point
you have to take it by word and if
someone says that they're not vaccinated
then
the whole company can't go back okay
this is this is sort of evolving at the
very moment
and this is where things get very
dangerous we're all allowed to make
our own choices i know that makes people
very uncomfortable i know that makes
nancy pelosi very uncomfortable that
people are gonna come up to her and
cough in her face
and she's very frail i understand that
but again with the alcohol in her i feel
like it would kill a lot of the germs
um but this is going to be a huge
problem this is going to be a huge
problem because
blue states will basically have it's not
just the rules you know let's put aside
the rules for a second
it's it's the culture of fear where
everyone will be looking at everyone
you're not wearing a mask were you
vaccinated can i see something that
proves you were vaccinated do you have a
qr code
stamped on your forehead like that is
what is far more worrying to me the
general culture of fear
and the way we will be able to
manipulate people in the future
far more than what the office of
occupational and health standards board
is telling people what to do but also
this is an odd outsourcing
i shouldn't say odd i suppose this is an
obvious outsourcing of government
responsibility
the government knows it can't get away
with a vaccine passport right now
because it would violate your right to
to privacy and medical records and all
sorts of stuff but if they can sort of
have
guidelines to tell companies that oh you
should probably do this with your
employees well in essence
that's sort of the government telling
you those things and and we know
that this is what they're doing which by
the way is consistent with what the
democrats have done remember that
clip we showed what six eight months ago
during the big tech hearings where aoc
was in essence saying hey
we no we can't regulate speech so you
better talking to mark zuckerberg
and he looked at her in a human moment i
mean i'm pretty sure the guy's a robot
but he looked at her and he's like well
lady i can't do that
i can't do that like that's not my job
and it's against the government job but
so you want to outsource the tyranny
of government to the private companies
and hopefully people will push back
lin says was it difficult to interview
michael mallis
what did you think of his outfit so if
you didn't see it yet and i hope you did
i interviewed michael malus last week we
just put it up in the last couple days
and he was dressed as q
from the dc comics and i did not know
what he was dressed as he told me he was
coming
to be dressed as something and he did
not want me to see him before we did the
interview live so i was
in here when i sat down he did his thing
with my guys and then we
you can see the beginning of the
interview when i actually see him i
swear to you
i thought it was just my suspicion
that he was going to come dressed up as
bee arthur from the golden girls
dorothy's bornak because he loves the
golden girls he knows i love the golden
girls
you may remember that the time before
that he was in studio with me he dressed
up as tulsi gabbard he wore
one of her white pantsuits and i just
had a feeling it was going to be be
arthur and he was going to do the entire
thing in drag and make me ask him about
politics
but instead he drew he dressed up as cue
we had a great interview you know it was
funny because
for the first minute or two you know
there's this weird thing it's like are
you going to do this the whole time like
we we did over an hour like are you
gonna
not take this thing off and everything
else and the suit was pretty awesome and
the mask was amazing i think someone in
his locals community actually made him
the mask
um but you know he's so good he's such a
clear thinker he has such an incisive
way of speaking that but pretty much
after like three minutes
it was it was sort of like yeah you know
like
uh you're you and that's the way we're
gonna do it so i love malice i just love
them
uh all right what's next i i want to try
to do as many of them quick as possible
i'm joining uh
seb gorka on newsmax right after this so
i got to go quick uh dave
have you this is curtis have you
mentioned you have mentioned ein rand
occasionally what made you attracted to
her writings and
philosophy objectivism look the ideas of
individual rights it is your
job in this earth on this planet
to fight for what is yours and that you
shouldn't be outsourcing your decision
making to
to the government or to anyone else i
think is pretty great i would say i have
a lot in common with the objectivists
i've always enjoyed going to
ein rand events these are people who
take ideas seriously love to debate
don't mind
disagreement on stuff which is really
awesome there was a fabulous event that
i did with jordan peterson
and euron brook and a couple people from
ari there was major disagreement about
belief
right because jordan is a believer and
believe believes that's at the root
of the individual they don't
objectivists
generally speaking don't believe in
belief they don't they don't they are
atheists
and thus there's a huge argument to be
had there we had a great discussion it
was completely respectful and everybody
was hugging and smiling and
taking pictures after all good brett
says when do you think kamala will be
taking over as president
she seems to be just hanging out in the
wings until the transition i mean the
question is either biden just fully
breaks down
and it's too obvious and they have to do
it or they just push him out
you know he'll just announce right
before the next election that he's not
going to do it
it's one of those two things i suppose
they've pushed him this far and although
it does seem to be accelerating
maybe he makes it to the end of the term
but i'd still be surprised i'd still be
surprised
tim says how can we make the thomas soul
interview happen with jordan peterson
so jordan i believe had tweeted at the
soul account which is technically not
run
by seoul but i know he's tweeted that he
wanted to have seoul on the show we
actually looped in
jordan's people with the soul people so
i hope hope hope hope
that it happens cece says when you were
a liberal were your
views of the world as skewed as current
liberals especially regarding a subject
like israel
um you know i've always said that
although you know look
the book right behind me is a defense of
liberalism and and now it's a
i'm a conservative i get it i get it and
by conservative i mean i love this
country i want to conserve freedom i
believe in individual rights
and the constitution i want people to
make decisions for themselves and all of
that stuff
that makes you a conservative it doesn't
mean we all have to agree on every
little thing
including abortion i think by the way um
but i want to conserve this freaking
thing and i
and and people on the right are decent
and tolerant and good
they're treated horribly by the media
and i can't find anyone
decent on the left anymore basically i
can find people who think that they're
on the left
but just don't realize it and i know it
takes some time like it takes some time
i get it we're gonna we gotta build that
bridge move those people over
um i don't think i was ever as
completely
bananas as the left is now i i but you
know what that's for somebody else to
judge not me i guess you could go back
and watch
my videos i honestly i i was thinking
wrong
about things i did not understand the
fundamental issues properly
and as i always say the reason woke-ism
and modern leftism has caught on is
because it's a mind virus a virus is
very easy to catch and hard to get rid
of
it's very easy to catch an idea where
you're told everyone who disagrees with
you is a racist
boy that feels pretty good everyone that
disagrees with you with a bigot and a
homophobe
and all that they're the worst things in
the world and you're the best thing in
the world it's the easiest virus to
catch
and it's very hard to get rid of but we
welcome the refugees
kendall says i joined locals just to
participate in your q a all right here
we go
here's my question if you and david were
coming over for a dinner at our house in
florida
what kind of bourbon should my wife and
i have ready to serve because i'm a
bourbon guy i'd love to share
a dram or two with you one day first off
i will be in florida and maybe we're
going to do a meet-up
i'm going to be there june 17th to 20th
i'm interviewing the mayor
of miami who's just absolutely awesome
francis suarez who's just
building a tech empire in miami which is
just great and
there's just a lot happening in miami
i'll leave it at that for now um
and as for the bourbon you know i'm more
of a tequila guy i've been big on
you know i'm a wine guy and a tequila
guy so i'll leave the bourbon up to you
uh but if now that you're in the locals
community we do these meetups where i
only tell the locals people where i am
because i can't have these lunatics
finding out where i am and it's worked
out well so far um i probably just blew
it right there we had a good run
um but i leave the bourbon up to you and
uh
what did well connor you brought over a
monkey monkey shoulder
monkey shoulder that's a whiskey i think
though but we knocked that thing out
i mean oh the headache anywho guys
uh part one of my interview with uh
david horowitz who was the original
why i left the left guy david's in his
80s now
he was a communist and a marxist his
political evolution is
is just extraordinary to watch uh part
one is up right now and the full episode
is also on locals right now
and for the first time ever we actually
had to edit
something for the purposes of youtube
when
when i do this show when i do my
interviews we don't edit for content
only once before in all the years that
we've done it you know we've edited if
someone really had a coughing fit or
something like that
um or one time the power went out like
some weird things like that but we've
never edited for content
i only did it once before because one of
my guests showed up really drunk and
stoned and i we the interview was just
crazy so we just felt we had to do that
um although i wasn't happy about it but
this interview with david horowitz we
actually had to edit out a couple lines
because he
said some stuff as a free person in the
free country of america
that would get this channel deleted off
youtube and
the truth is i have a business to run
and employees to pay and everything else
so we did follow the youtube rules
and we cut those pieces we actually
edited them we put in a sound bar and
all that
part one is up right now part two which
has the the edited stuff will be on
youtube but you're not going to hear the
stuff because we're just going to be
bleeping it out but if you want to
listen to the full thing
it's so funny i started a tech company
because i knew all this was
coming
uh and you can watch the full episode
right now at reubenreport.locals.com
and guess what we're not going to ban me
you know there isn't going to be a
meeting dave we'd like to sit down with
you we're
banning you dave uh friday guys the
panel is back tomorrow we have former
congressman trey
raydell we have spencer clavin who i've
wanted to have on the show forever and
nicole
saffier uh it's going to be an
interesting one we're just doing a sort
of a
news recap i've been doing these fridays
on sort of specific topics
but i just felt like there's just so
much going on this week that let's just
do like a full-on
recap uh anyway enjoy the day everybody
hope you hope you enjoy the show hope
you're feeling good about life and the
way of the world things are gonna be all
right
i'll be joining uh seb gorka on newsmax
is that live
i know i'm i'll be live in about five
minutes so
i will see you there i'll be wearing the
same thing what will you be wearing
goodbye